قال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الرياض
كوفي انه من غير المجد التحدث هو مع كيف
بعد قرار واشنطن تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
واضاف هذه القبض في تصريحات لوكاله هيريا
نوفوتي عندما اعلنت واشنطن قرارها تزويد
كيف بالدبابات فان من سماهم اتباعها
تنافسوا على من وكم سيزود اوكرانيا
بالدبابات واشار ان يبقى كوفت الا انه من
غير الوجديه التحدث ليس فقط مع من سماهم
النازيين الاوكرانيين ولكن ايضا مع محركيا
الدمى وفق تعبيرها وفي موضوع صله وصفهاريه
خاصه المفاوضات بشان طاقه امنه حول محطه
زباله نوويه بانها صعبه مجتهما كيف باللعب
على العامل الوقت وبلشان تبادل السجناء
معه
من غير المحتمل ان تكون هناك خيارات
واقعيه في هذا الملف مثيرا لانه موسكو
مستمر تنفي تبادل المعلومات بشان السجناء
ولكن المساله تحتاج الى الصمت بحسب قوله